[Musique]
à cause de la pandémie et de choses comme
les festivals, les cafés, les restaurants, les pubs, les
gymnases, tout est pratiquement fermé et donc
l'agence de création peu commune de Londres
nous a contactés et vous savez, j'essaie d'
utiliser le parfum comme un capteur évocateur
qui doit rappeler  les gens de tous
leurs endroits préférés
[Musique]
donc pour celui-ci, notre traduction
était de travailler avec des parfums comme le
houblon, la bière, la bière et le gingembre, mais
aussi de les associer à une touche vraiment
fumée, nous avons donc utilisé du Cade qui est un
essentiel très puissant  l'huile donc l'idée
était d'essayer de créer l'idée d'une
table de café en plein air avec un verre de pinte vide et
une décharge de cigarettes à l'intérieur de la copie sur celle-
ci est un résident oh désolé un
bouquet résident d'herbe coupée, de peau brûlée et
de cidre réchauffé par le soleil attaché  avec un ruban de
douce fumée de cannabis donc l'idée d'
être dans un champ en train d'écouter ton
groupe préféré
donc il y a de l'herbe à coq là-dedans mais
il y a aussi du chanvre et puis nous avons des
notes douces ainsi que de la saleté
[Musique]
toi